For the CPU code we'll actually just look at three lines of C source code
without worrying about details like allocating memory or initializing the array.
Here's our code. The first line is setting up the loop.
We're going to loop from i = 0 until i = 63,
incrementing i each time we walk through the loop.
What are we going to do on each iteration of the loop?
We're going to fetch the input value at array location i,
multiply it times itself and store it into the output array.
There's two interesting things to note about this code.
One, we have only one thread of execution,
and that thread explicitly loops over all of its input.
We define thread here as one independent path of execution through the code.
This definition is also going to apply to our GPU code.
Two, note this code has no explicit parallelism. This is serial code.
There's only one thread and it loops 64 times, doing one computation per iteration.